so I went on already pissed and um he
was this like British guy this older
British guy was wasted and um it was
Halloween and I just did kind of like a
hacky Your mom joke where I just went on
it's so weird like that you're here you
know because I've been planning my
costume I was gonna go as your mom for
Halloween but I really couldn't fit I
couldn't fit all the dicks in my mouth
it just wasn't big enough and the man
got so mad it was hilarious he got so
pissed so then he stands up he's like
don't talk about my and I'm cocky
thinking security is around but this was
back in the day when The Comedy Store
was not what it was what it is now it
had a little lapse in uh security for a
second but I thought I was good so I'm
talking so much [ __ ] to this guy he
stands up because don't ever talk about
my mom I go oh my God I didn't realize
your mom was like that big of a [ __ ]
that you thought I would actually know
her like I don't even I'm not even from
your country right like I'm not doubling
down [ __ ] you I'm in the show so then he
starts to charge the mound like he's
coming at me and I'm like uh security
security